معنا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي ما رايك عميد الياس
ان نبدا من هذه النقطه مقالته وكاله توتاس
ان اصدر قانونا باخضاع المواطنين بين
اعمار 18 عاما وثلاثين عاما للتجنيد
الاجباري
عثمان الانتقال الى الازمه في العديد لدى
روسيا وهذا الامر هو لتهريب الخبر اذا صح
التعبير من موضوع ان العمليه لا تزال
عمليه عسكريه خاصه يعني هي ليست حرب كي
يتم الحشد الحربي الصناعي العسكري وحتى
حشد البلاد ككل ولكن بالتالي قولنت هذا
الوضع لمزيد من العسكر وكان الحرب ستكون
طويله فاذا اليوم عاده يمنع الخدمه
الالزاميه او الخدمه الاجباريه يمنع من
نشرها خارج البلاد اليوم عندما تضم اربعه
اقاليم بمرسوم رسمي اساسي روسي وكانك تنشر
هذه القوات على ارض الروسيه دائما هناك من
يقول ان باستطاعه روسيا اليوم
تجنيد ما يقارب 2.4 مليون عدا من يقاتل في
اوكرانيا او داخل الجبهات ديروسيه او داخل
الجهات في روسيه لكن انت امام حرب طويله
العديد مهم يبقى العتاد الذخيره المشكله
الاكبر لروسيا وحتى لاوكرانيا طيب ابقى
معنا عميد الياس نلقي نظره على التطورات
الاخيره في هذه الحرب التي تميزت اذا
بالتركيز على جبهه جديده في الصراع هي
جبهه الموانئ فميناء نوفروسيس في البحر
الاسود الذي اعلنت القوات الاوكرانيه
استهدافه هو اكبر ميناء في روسيا ويعد
استراتيجيا للغايه باعتباره مفترق طرق
للنقل الدولي بين روسيا والبحر الابيض
المتوسط ومناطق في اسيا يحمل هذا الميناء
الرقم القياسي للموانئ الروسيه من حيث طول
خط الرسوم الذي يتجاوز ثمانيه كيلو مترات
وتستمر الملاحه فيه على مدار العام تقريبا
افتتح عام
1945 لاستقبال السفن الروسيه والاجنبيه
القادمه من الخارج وبفضله اصبحت التجاره
البحريه النشاط الرئيسي لسكان مدينه
نوفروسيسك وكانت روسيا بدورها قد استهدفت
قبل يومين من اسماعيل الاوكراني ايضا هو
احد اهم موانئ الحبوب تصدير الحبوب جنوب
غربيه اوديسا ويقع على نهر الدانوب على
الحدود مع رومانيا وادى استهدافه لتعطيل
العمل فيه وتسجيل ارتفاع في اسعار الحبوب
نعود اليك العميد الياس
يبدو ان ما يحدث هو حرب
موانئ كيف تنظر اليها
عثمان هذا هذا المرفا هو مهم جدا اثنين
بالمئه من تصدير النفط الى العالم هو يصل
بحر ازوف حتى ببحر قزوين عبر قناه الدون
فاذا لهذا الامر مهم جدا وهو روسي وليس
مثل سيلفاستوبول المشكله او المهم اليوم
انه هناك حرب مسيرات جويه
بحريه وحتى بريه عثمان هناك القوات
الاوكرانيه تستعمل مسيرات بريه لنزع
الالغام فاذا نحن امام مسيرات بحريه من
صنع محلي ذات مدى بعيد 700 كم كيف تستطيع
القوات الاوكرانيه ان ترسل هذه المسيره
الى هذه المسافه وحتى الى جسر قرش فاذا
انت امام مرحله جديده امام 400 الف كيلو
متر مربع مساحه البحر الاسود تضاف الى 600
الف كيلو متر مربع في اوكرانيا فاذا نحن
امام مليون كيلو متر مربع من الصراع بحر
جو بر وحتى سيبر اني وحتى مدفعيه وحتى
صواريخ وفرد صوتيه وما شابه عثمان ولكن
هذا يدفعني لسؤالك عن
المسيرات انت كخبيره عسكري عن الدور التي
باتت تلعبها المسيرات في الدور في الحروب
الحديثه عندما تتحدث عن ان هناك مسيرات
ليس فقط جويه ولكن بحريه وبريه ايضا
المسيرات هي الاقل كلفه ليس لها كلفه
بشريه
والجديد عثمان ان في اوكرانيا هذه
المسيرات او التلوكه هي المسيره البحريه
السطحيه هي مسيره من صنع محلي يعني ليس
عليها قيود اساسيه من الغرب لاستعمالها ضد
الاراضي الروسيه حتى المسيرات البيفر او
اليوجي 22 التي تقصف داخل الاراضي الروسيه
حتى العاصمه والاستمرار فيها وكان هناك
سياسه اصبحت واستراتيجيه ومقاربه اوكرانيه
كلها من صنع محلي وكاننا نرى ان هناك
عمليه
اختبار كبير لكل المسيرات وهناك صناعه
للمسيرات تستعمل الذكاء الاصطناعي في مكان
وهي متقدمه وهي تصنع تجرب على ارض الواقع
وبالتالي يعود التحديث لها مباشره الى من
صنعها العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
متحدثا من بيروت شكرا لك